Далі діяти будемо ми!
Цими словами з пісні Віктора Цоя звертається
до українців партія Міхеіла Саакашвілі
зі сторінок своєї газети.
Партія скандально відомого політика готується до 17 жовтня,
коли біля парламенту зберуться учасники
всеукраїнської акції протесту.
. Вони оголосять свої вимоги президенту
і парламенту щодо виконання виборчих обіцянок,
зокрема про скасування депутатської недоторканості,
створення антикорупційного суду і ухвалення
прозорого виборчого законодавства.
Якщо влада не відреагує, учасники протесту
вимагатимуть проведення дострокових виборів.
Якщо президент хоче, а парламент на це не йде,
то президент має розпустити Верховну Раду.
Якщо парламент хоче, а президент ні, то тоді,
можливо, Рада має висунути вимогу, щоб президент пішов.
Але все це залежатиме від того, як вони будуть діяти.
Насправді, це вони пишуть історію.
Саакашвілі категорично відхиляє будь-яке
силове захоплення парламенту.
Хоча серед учасників можуть бути радикальні активісти,
політик запевняє: акція буде суто мирною.
Нового Майдану чекати не слід, принаймні такого,
до якого звикли українці.
Мені здається, що Майдан Україні не пасує,
це неможливо.
По-перше, ніхто не збирається нападати на людей,
заважати їм висловлювати свої думки,
принаймні з боку правоохоронних органів.
Такого ресурсу у влади зараз немає.
По-друге, такого поділу між регіонами,
який був до Майдану, немає.
Сьогодні Захід, Схід, Північ, Південь країни єдині
у своїх вимогах як ніколи.
Раніше такого не було.
Цю ситуацію політик поясняє помилками влади,
зокрема президента Порошенка,
який, за словами Саакашвілі,
обіцяв продати свої бізнес-активи, але так і не продав.
Крім того, не виконав вимогу Майдану
щодо припинення монополії олігархів
у стратегічній енергетичній галузі.
Якщо ми йдемо в Євросоюз, то неможливо діяти
за правилами Росії, неможливо діяти
за правилами путінської системи.
Українська політична еліта хоче жити, як на Рубльовці,
і водночас мати безвіз з Європою і вважатися Європою.
Так не вийде. Або ти - частина руського миру,
або ти - частина Європи.
Але тоді ти приборкуєш свої апетити,
дієш у межах верховенства права, тоді ти не можеш
перетворити державний апарат на особисту прислугу,
натомість ти маєш іти на зустріч народу.
В Україні ще немає умов для появи
справжнього народного президента,
який хотів би розмовляти з людьми напряму.
Вважає політик, відомий своїми виходами в народ ще у Грузії.
Він не бажає іти в президенти України.
Принаймні допоки не буде виконана ще одна вимога
Євромайдану - десовєтізація української політеліти.